foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsey show where that is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they actually love and create amazing
relationships open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Christina Ellis number one best-selling
author and Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so last week I was off for the entire
week we were doing an entree leadership
Master Series where we were teaching
leadership to small business people we
had on just under a thousand folks in
attendance at that it's usually a fairly
small event like that and this one was
and I've got to spend a lot of time with
small business people and of course men
I was off the air during the time the
hurricane hits Florida so a little
little late to the game on this old news
but uh prayers to those of you that are
waiting through what you're waiting
through there I'm sorry for you and um I
am Christina getting some interesting
emails into the into our email inbox at
just at the Ramsey uh uh uh concierge we
call it or Ramsey uh customer area and
uh the number of people that are sending
an email going I don't know exactly what
I'm going to find when I get back down
there I just read one a minute ago I
said basically this I don't know what
I'm fine when I get back to my house but
I do know this I'm 100 Dead free house
and everything I've got flood insurance
um we're safe we're fine we left got out
we're going back and
there's no U-Haul trucks following a
hearse so you're not taking it with you
anyway so whatever stuff is stuff his
stuff is torn up we're gonna fix it and
uh
it's a way different
email or emotional state to be in if you
are prepared for something like this
financially Yeah we actually had people
come to the lobby last week who were
running from the hurricane and came and
stopped in here to visit us and kind of
heard that sentiment of like wow this is
awful I don't know what I'm going to go
back to but I have peace in my finances
and peace in my home because I'm not
actually stressed about you know a lack
of preparedness yeah because I mean
we've been since I don't know Katrina
really we've been pounding on flood
insurance for those that are within
range of a storm surge because we
discovered during Katrina that uh when
State Farm took them all the way to the
state supreme court to make sure that
they didn't pay uh for their house being
torn down because it was a flood not a
hurricane
ouch although the flood was caused by a
hurricane I'm still pissed about this
years later but anyway uh so they've
separated the two successfully in the
insurance industry now so you better
make sure you've got flood insurance if
you're within a storm surge because
that's the thing which we've been
hitting that hard and of course we've
been hitting hard being debt free and
having an emergency fund and having your
finances in order be the third Pig in
The Three Little Pigs the one with the
brick house not YOLO Pig you only live
once with the straw house because the
big bad wolf will huffle and puff and
the metaphor really plays here
YOLO Pig Yeah
Ian Ian the wolf right right huffed and
he puffed and he blew their house down
oh my God for real that's really awful
I'm gonna use that now yeah don't be
YOLO Pig don't be YOLO Pig if you be the
third Pig and so our our hearts go out
to all of you that have been affected in
Florida and our prayers go out to you uh
you've certainly been in all of the
nation's thoughts and prayers uh through
this period of time and the good news is
literally hundreds of thousands of
people are on their way to help in the
time people are doing all kinds of
things Americans don't make the news uh
for being who they are always but who
who Americans are is unbelievably
generous and unbelievably good to people
who are in trouble and so the uh the
number of people uh putting up electric
lines down there right now that are not
from Florida is in the tens of thousands
of people came with bucket trucks from
other states wow and so uh to help put
Florida back together again and um and
as it should be you know as it should be
you are you ought to you know the
neighbor's barn burns down everybody I
gather up and build them a barn I like
that yeah uh that that's generosity
that's not socialism there's a
difference and so
um people being good to each other is
always a good thing so you guys in
Florida we love you uh we're thinking
about you
and um you know all of us here all over
America have friends we've been checking
in with and wondering what was going on
uh Pete young one of our top leaders
here his mom and dad and brother are all
in in uh Tampa St Pete so we're checking
minute by minute because he was working
a live event with us this week up here
and uh you know everybody we're all just
checking in with everybody and all that
so uh the point is you don't know when
the big bad wolf is going to come or
what form he takes he might be a
quarantine
um he might be a
you know he might be uh your company
goes broke and you didn't know anything
about it and you get laid off tomorrow
um he might be uh gas doubles at the gas
at the gas pump and all of a sudden uh
there's a Biden sticker on there I did
it I did that you know I mean there's
there's always something right is
something happening and uh so being
prepared is your only option and it's
not just sitting around being prepared
for bad things it also actually
positions you to prosper in good times
when things are going right for you so
uh the stuff that we teach here it's for
everyone if you're looking for snotty
PhD level finance class
you're gonna be disappointed here
because the only PhD around here is John
deloney and me I have a PhD in d-u-m-b
if you've done stupid I've done it
bigger so I got you beat so I'll call
you stupid and me stupid at the same
time and we'll just be stupid together
for a little bit and then we won't be
stupid anymore and we'll move on that's
what we do it's called learning right
and so we've all screwed up well you
know if you've made mistakes with money
that makes you um
over 12. there you go everybody has and
so this is the show for you this is the
place for you Ramsey is the place for
you we do not exist for people that
think you need a master's in finance to
win with money we have lots of data that
indicates has nothing to do with it yep
well and I feel like now we're in this
culture where everybody needs to wants
to have the secret they want to have the
hidden secret to survive a recession of
this hidden secret and it's there's not
really a secret five things to do to
survive inflation yeah five things you
should do if there is no inflation oh
they're the same things who knew Common
Sense wow
be generous live on less than you make
be on a budget get out of debt save and
invest oh B there's a plan get out you
know these are these are things that
work every time and they come from you
know Grandma or in some of your cases
great grandma
um I used to say gods and Grandma's ways
of handling things some of you are young
enough that your grandma was stupid so
um you know we need to go Great Grandma
for some of you but to go back and find
common sense in our culture but it's
there and it's real and we're here to
help you with it so you call in we'll
walk with you on your money stuff and on
your relationship stuff and on your
career stuff they all work together and
at Ramsey we've got a Dr John deloney
we've got a Ken Coleman and we've got
all the rest of us working on the money
stuff and so we'll weave all that
together and make sure you get a good
answer and it'll always be on a shelf
that you can reach the cookies I put the
cookies down low I like cookies and I
want to be able to reach them and I'm
just not that tall so we want to put the
cookies on a shelf where everyone can
reach them and if that insults your
intelligence then it's okay move along
and hang out with the intelligent people
we'll just be regular people with a big
pile of money this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Rams energy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Christine Ellis Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk paying off that
is smart saving and investing is smart
but there's one key to winning with
money that people Overlook and that is
protecting your finances from
emergencies this is where the right
kinds of insurance come into play
there's 10 kinds of insurance coverage
you might need the rest of them you
probably don't need and we built a tool
called the coverage checkup to show you
which types you need to add drop or
adjust we'll even rank your coverage
list by importance email it to you
connect you with a Ramsey trusted
insurance provider all this is free it
could take could be the most important
five minutes you spend Donald wrote in
and said uh uh for anyone who has not
completed this checkup do it right now
you never know when something will
happen and you never want to leave your
family in a bad situation
ramseysolutions.com checkup that's
ramsaysolutions.com dot com slash
checkup Nick starts off this hour in
Minneapolis hi Nick welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey man thanks for having me sure what's
up
well brace for impact here uh I have a
residential and commercial cleaning
business that I run solo so no employees
and like I just I work a crazy amount of
hours like a busy week I'll do nine to
three and then go back out and work from
like seven to eleven so I know it's time
to start hiring like that soil I'm gonna
scale it but you know I just have some
concerns that probably any other
business owner would have and that's
like the quality of my Replacements like
the consistency of work just because of
the industry that I'm in like there's a
lot of changes in my clients
particularly the houses and then like
the extra cost of the software and just
the legalities and just all this stuff
and I'm just trying to get out of this
rut because I should have probably hired
like two years ago and I'm really to the
point that I'm just like burned out you
know you're gonna fry out what you're
doing is not sustainable you've got to
get some help or you gotta or you got to
raise your prices and lower the number
of clients one of the two
sure yeah so man hiring is very
difficult because there's all this
mythology around it number one the labor
Market's real tough right now
so it's hard to get people right now to
do anything uh most businesses are
struggling the people we spent time with
last week entree leaders are number
number one thing they're struggling with
getting good people right now it's
always been hard to get good people
right now is extra special tough so that
that being said here's what you're
looking for
you've got to go slow enough to get the
right people
okay yeah don't bring on the wrong
people because you get desperate and
you're late to the party so you need to
get with it
but you need to spend enough time one
interview won't do it you've got to
interview them more than one time at a
minimum of four times you ought to sit
down with them separate times to figure
out what kind of a person that you're
going to lend your name to because
everyone that works for you is in
marketing
because if they screw up something the
customer is going to tell everybody that
your whole business is a screw-up
if they do something if they do
something right there your customer is
going to tell everybody that your whole
business is great
and so with a thousand folks on plus
almost 1100 people on the Ramsey team if
one of them screws up and I may not even
know them but it doesn't matter they all
go well that Dave Ramsey
you know
immediately I get blamed which is I mean
that's what I signed up for so I'm not
I'm not bitching about it but that's
what you're signing up for so not
delegating to someone who you aren't
comfortable with you hire them first and
you haven't trained them yet you can't
just hand them the keys to the kingdom
and walk away and oh no I don't want to
be control freak that's not a control
freak that's called training
because you're turning over your
reputation to these people
and so the the rule on delegation is
this and it's in the book entree
leadership I'll send you a copy of it
it's easy to delegate to Christina
when she goes on a major television
program and answers questions on behalf
of her and on behalf of Ramsey on say
Fox News I can delegate that to
Christina she's sitting beside me I can
delegate that because I can trust two
things about her that I know that I know
that I know because we've spent enough
time together training we've spent
enough time together to get to know each
other and here's the two things I know I
can trust her competency
she can answer the question correctly
with a smile her on camera ability is
excellent
the camera likes her she likes the
camera that's why she's on there more
often than I am and so that you know and
I can trust her integrity
she's going to do the right thing if
someone Corners her in an adversarial
interview on camera she's still going to
do the right thing she's going to be
sweeter about it than I would but she's
still going to do the right thing and so
when you can trust their integrity and
their competency they are trained to be
able to turn something over to them and
you can still sleep at night and that's
not being a micromanager that's called
being a wise business owner
that's good well in this market with so
much competition for jobs and a lot of
employers struggling to find employees
how can a small business like Nix stand
out and get high quality people who have
integrity well number one uh you're
going to have to pay them well
not overpay them but you cannot be at
the bottom shelf you're going to get
what you pay for in that sense number
two you've got to give them the Dignity
of speaking into their Destiny and into
the destiny of the whole company
and so everyone at Ramsey's always
talking to each other and to me and
everybody in the whole place about how
we can all get better we're all trying
to figure out which play to win to run
to win the Super Bowl and we argue about
it oh I think we ought to throw it no I
think we ought to run it no I think we
ought to run at the left I think we
ought to run at the right I don't care I
mean we're always arguing but we're
arguing about one thing how do we score
and win the Super Bowl and so you got to
get people involved with their dignity
and that kind of thing the second the
last thing and I told these small
business owners this last week working
for corporate America sucks
even if you make more money you're
treated like a freaking number and they
will throw your butt in the street at
the first sign of a stock downturn
you'll be the first one thrown out of
there so oh that guy makes a lot of
money dump him that guy makes a lot of
money dump him Corporate America has no
soul it's a transaction when you're
running a small family business you're
working with the owner or right beside
the owner or you see the owner quite
often you know you have an advantage
because you actually treat people like
people it's just your nature and people
would rather work for a small business
assuming the pay is reasonable because
the environment is a thousand times
better than corporate stupid but America
that's lost its mind
I'm telling you man you don't want to
work over there and people people
sometimes leave here and go to work over
there and they'll call me up Dave I made
a huge mistake yes you did
[Laughter]
yes you did well I know here a lot of
people love the culture working at
Ramsey that's one of the big things that
people talk about people love just the
environment here the people who are here
and that's exciting but I think a lot of
small business owners you know when
they're first hiring they're not
thinking about setting an intentional
culture which it's important from day
one it's important from employee number
one yeah but I figured out with our
first like 10 employees we didn't have
you know what our benefits were your
check cleared that's a good benefits
package your check was good you know
that we had no benefits the benefit was
you got paid and it actually went into
the bank and everything shut up you know
and so you know if you want some health
insurance go get you some this was
before it was required you know if you
want some of this go get you some uh you
know you don't have that no I don't have
that I don't even know what that is you
want time off try making some bunch of
money so you can get some time off and
so you know this is uh uh this is how we
started and so we didn't have any we
couldn't compete and we still don't try
to compete head on with the corporate
America benefits package if you want a
benefits package then you're probably
not a Ramsay team member we've got great
benefits nowadays but if you cut you
know but you come here for other stuff
you can get more binnies somewhere else
but you're good to your people from day
one in front of the human transaction
right that's your brand advantage that's
what we tell people in the older days we
got no benefits your check clears that's
your only benefit but guess what we're
working on something that matters and
we're working on this crusade to help
people change their lives and change
their family trees if you want to be
part of something that's big and it's
moving this is where it's going to be
and we'll always share with you if we
make some money but we'll also share
with you if we're starving to death yep
and I think that's how you have people
like in staff meeting this morning we
celebrated somebody who had has been
here for 20 years and I feel like we're
often celebrating people who've been
here from the beginning and they just
love the humans they love you know
serving on this Crusade with you because
you've been awesome to them well it's
you treat people like people treat
people right instead of treating them
like a transaction like a robot they're
not a unit of production I mean
you know people have kids and grandkids
and the dog is sick and there's you know
they have lives and and you actually can
treat them like that if you're a small
business and that's your brand Advantage
when you're hiring that's what you're
looking for Nick and um but then just
make sure you're delegating to people
you can trust their competency and their
integrity hold on we'll get you a copy
of the entree leadership book and send
it out to you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ellis Ramsey personality is my co-host
today in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
and by the way drive by and see us if
you're out and about we're just south of
Nashville and Franklin Tennessee one of
the best towns in the world we're right
down here in the Ramsey headquarters are
here and you come in visit the lobby
there's free coffee and homemade cookies
and all kinds of stuff to see and do
including the debt free stage where Ryan
is standing hey Ryan welcome to the
Ramsay show honor honor to be here sir
good to have you brother where do you
live uh Pentwater Michigan it's about an
hour and a half north of Grand Rapids
right on Lake Michigan oh yeah very cool
welcome to Nashville all right and here
to do with that free scream how much did
you pay off just over 103 000. good and
your range of income I'm sorry how long
did that take 36 months 36 months and
your range of income through those three
years I started at like 110 and this
year it'll probably be close to 128.
good what do you do for a living man I'm
a feeder driver for UPS drive semi truck
wow good for you well you're working a
lot of hours good for you man all right
so 103 000 of what kind of debt all
mortgage you paid off your house yes sir
yeah
dude way to go look at weird people how
old are you just turned 39 they actually
paid last payment the day before my
birthday which September 23rd same day
uh you could declare bankruptcy yeah
okay yeah all right well better for you
than me yeah yes good all right so
you're a single 39 year old truck driver
yep with a paid for stinking house yes
sir you rock thank you what's the house
worth uh
250 maybe uh I don't know you look on
Zillow and it's way higher than that but
I wouldn't go by that I wouldn't go by
that either but it's probably more than
250 then yeah good for you man yep so
tell me your Ramsay story what inspired
you to do all of this uh I started
working at a fairly young age
um 15. I worked at my grandpa's car
dealership
um but what got me really started was I
worked for a sign company small company
there was five of us and that included
the owner and his wife and me and the
owner would we did sign work up and down
West Michigan and we'd listen to your
show in the afternoons and
first year we had the Christmas party it
was small enough we just had other house
and they had your financial piece
Revisited book and we'd been listening
for you know months on so I borrowed
that book and that put me down the
rabbit hole uh since then I've I think I
counted up I've gotten 15 year books
um
I've read more of your books than I read
through any of my high school or college
especially start to finish
um
but it's yeah I went to a live event in
2010 yeah
um got in touch with one of your
financial uh
approved people in 2012 and started my
my uh
Ira how much have you got on investments
uh I looked the other day and
unfortunately it's down at like 200 but
it it's a good amount for okay for right
now so so you're well over a half
million dollar net worth of 39 years old
yes well done sir yeah congratulations
I'm proud of you thank you very very
cool what a great birthday gift to
yourself yeah when I when I bought my
house the goal was to be by 40 and then
I came here three years ago and that's
what you know I I got intentional after
that and it was you know Dave ish for a
while but
three years ago it was just you know
let's you know I put the the paper on
the I started the list on the
refrigerator and every time you know I
saw it and that put me more focused on
yeah uh just every every payment marking
it down and extra payments and we're
real busy through you know Thanksgiving
through Christmas time at UPS and
extra income just tack that on and Tack
it on and
yeah you did it early yeah good job
that's awesome so what did this
debt-free journey look like what was
what was the hardest part what were some
of the key things you did just being
intentional not being you know not
letting normal take over
um you know
just
just following the plan it's not like
it's 30 steps it's seven and just
one step at a time just like you know
the the Dave's saying you know how do
you eat an elephant one step in a one
bite at a time and
you just have to follow the plan it's
not rocket science it's not complicated
just follow the plan so many people say
that the plans you know it doesn't work
for me and give
countless excuses on why it doesn't work
it'll work that's why it doesn't work
exactly it doesn't work because you
didn't follow the plan if you follow the
plan it works and
it just you just have to commit to doing
the plan and once you commit to doing
the plan
that's what we were talking about
earlier it's not it's not crazy PhD
level math it's common sense you just
got to do it there's a couple pieces of
notebook paper on the refrigerator with
a couple of magnets and a guy who's a
detail-oriented guy UPS feels very safe
with him driving their trucks this guy's
a detail guy and so yeah you don't miss
anything I mean that handwriting
everything down that list it's all your
personality was revealed right then it's
awesome in a good way in a good way
you're a man of character well done sir
thank you well Don how's it feel to not
have a stinking payment in the world
it's been great it's uh did you sensor
release
yeah it's it's been or is it
anticlimactic it was it was
anticlimactic you know you make the
payment and you know worse Dead Come
fireworks no fireworks came off uh no
confetti cannon um but it's just
even once you're past baby step three
like just
if you fall down at work the next day if
you get laid off you you don't have any
payments and you have an emergency fund
it's you know it's gonna be you know
there's no emergencies it's an
inconvenience amen and now it's it's
even beyond that it's
now there's no house payment at all it's
just now determine where the money goes
it's almost I need a new list I don't
know it's almost boring yeah you don't
have to you have to really set a
millionaire goal here and lay it down
and start working towards that put that
on the refrigerator now that was going
to be my next question what what next
now that you're completely done free I I
got some house upgrades I'd like to do
um but even even through my journey I I
cash flowed I paid for an older Bronco
um a second vehicle
it was a collector yeah yeah it's not
but you're gonna build it up it's no
it's nice okay it's just like a summer
vehicle okay
um but you know it was just a toy yeah
it's a toy yeah but being intentional
and setting the money aside did you know
through it's baby steps four or five and
six it's you know if you want to be you
know have a sinking fund for that that's
the time to do it you know
way to go man who were your biggest
cheerleaders I see some very happy folks
mom and her boyfriend have been huge
huge cheerleaders uh my grandparents
have been awesome
um
it's
just don't let normal take over yeah so
one of the things we've always enjoyed
about being around Grand Rapids in
general the area there you're a little
bit north of there I know but uh it is
the the work ethic in that part of the
country it's kind of a Dutch thing it's
kind of a Midwestern thing going on but
you've got that work ethic you're not
afraid of hard work you just get with
something to stay on it yes and that's
uh that must have come from family yeah
yeah yeah well done very good stuff yeah
moms and dads if you teach somebody to
work and teach them to stay on something
in a culture where nobody knows how to
work and stay on something they're going
to be like rock stars that's what's
going to happen and so that's who you
are man way to go good stuff man way to
go it's awesome we got a copy of uh baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure a
financial peace membership for a year
and a Total Money Makeover book and uh
be sure and give some of those away and
be sure and read some of them yourself
and you've read everything back to front
you said already so maybe all of these
are giveaways we don't care we want to
give them to you you can pass the Love
on and somebody be inspired by your
story we're inspired by your story thank
you you're a hero thank you well done
I've actually given away The Total Money
Makeover I don't know how many times as
a wedding present yeah I'm sure it's a
coaster for many people but it is
there's a there's a few that have
actually opened it it actually it has
two lives it starts as a coaster and
then there's a moment in time that
people pick it up yes and so it's it is
the war world's best used coaster
without a doubt so I'm proud of that I'm
proud of that it works good for me stays
on the table it doesn't get thrown away
that's a good start we got it we got a
shot at it still all right Ryan from
Grand Rapids Michigan 100 103
000 paid off house and everything
36 months at 39 years old as a single
guy driving a truck a hundred and ten
thousand a hundred and twenty eight
thousand income counted down let's hear
a debt free scream three two one I'm
debt free yeah I know
that ladies and gentlemen is how it's
done if you thought you couldn't do it
you can do it we're gonna put the
cookies on a shelf or you can reach them
because that's the only place we can set
them this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Cameron is in Los
Angeles hi Cameron welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi thanks for taking my call today sure
what's up
hey so
um I need a little bit of help and
guidance from you
um I'm kind of where to start I'm a
little overwhelmed with a lot of my
finances I started yesterday by figuring
out some debts and I've I've realized
that I'm really behind on a lot of my
basic utilities and um and taxes and I'm
trying to get started on the baby steps
but I just feel so overwhelmed because
I'm behind in so many things
okay so I kind of need to know kind of
how to start on all this it's a scary
place isn't it brother
hell yeah how old are you
33. and what's your income
um I would say on average right now
about 30 000 ish a year what do you do
I work in the entertainment industry so
I do a lot of stuff for
um musical theater so anything from
costuming to wigs
um and all that kind of stuff okay
about how much debt do you think you
have
um well when I totaled it up yesterday
I'm gonna just probably uh rounding it
to about ten thousand dollars
[Music]
well you know what I know it's scary
right now but I just want to say good
job getting on board
like we're really happy that you're
calling today
thank you
yeah so here's the thing number one
we're going to send you a copy of the
book The Total Money Makeover
all right and that's what um uh close to
nine million people now I've got that
book and have used it and I'm not
selling your book I'm giving you one so
you don't you just have to read it
that's all you got to do now
um so here's what I would do in your
situation before you start the baby
steps you need to be current
with your utilities and current with
your bills so the first goal to get
current is make a list of what each bill
like the electric bill what's it take to
be current on the electric bill what's
it take to be current on the water bill
what's it take to be current on the dot
dot dot fill it in okay and that's just
to be current
you follow me and then your goal when
you do out your written budget is you're
going to budget out in any money you can
squeeze out of your budget you're going
to work down that list smallest to
largest
okay so like if it takes 20 bucks to get
a bill current whether and that's your
little one boom that one's Done Right
easy right it takes 50 bucks to get
another one boom that one's done that's
easy right and so the more of them you
get in the current side the the more
your stress is going to drop because
right now your stress level is like up
in your throat you're chewing on your
stomach
yeah you know what I'm saying I remember
that I used to remember that like I get
a little sweat in the palm of my hand a
little bit above my eyebrows and uh and
your heart rate goes up when you make
those lists of stuff and you just like
freaked out like you've jumped off a
building and you're just falling or
something you know what I'm talking
about
yeah yeah that's how you feel right
oh yeah yeah yes sir so more of that is
going to go away the more of this you
get and control the second thing is just
by making the list your stress level is
going to go down because now we've
Quantified the size of the Dragon
that must die this Dragon must die and
you are a night young man you're going
to kill the dragon
and it must die it may take a bunch of
cuts it may take a bunch of swings of
the sword uh you may get really tired
and you're definitely going to get some
blood on you but the dragon is gonna die
you're gonna kill it because you're just
the guy that's why you called us we're
dragging we're night trainers we're
going to train you to kill the dragon
all right you can do this yeah so
the second part of this equation is
there's two sides of the equation income
and outgo
thirty thousand dollars a year in Los
Angeles California as an income sucks
you're starving to death
you have got to do some stuff to add to
your income and I don't care if it's
something that's not pretty or not fun
if it what you need right now is some
Monday
ten thousand dollars would change your
life
can't say that about a lot of people
yeah so the good the bad news is you got
ten thousand dollars worth of debt the
good news is it's only ten thousand
dollars worth in other words if we
increase your income with a good strong
part-time job it's fifteen thousand a
year you're going to be debt free a
hundred percent in less than a year if
you just live on what you make at your
regular job
yeah so part-time job is in your future
I don't know if you're delivering Uber
Eats or if you're delivering pizzas or
if you're walking dogs or you're cutting
grass I don't care what it is but you
need to go do something for Monday good
money
don't take something cheap not minimum
wage I want you to make some money
and and just be I don't want you to do
anything illegal and I don't want you to
do anything immoral that puts your
ethics at risk anything like that but
short of that go get you some money
because ten thousand bucks have changed
your life that's pretty cool right now
that you can do that so my prediction is
you're going to be debt free in a year
yeah I would like to it you know I I
find it hard as well in my situation
because
um I make my income varies month to
month because the type of work that I do
yeah it varies from sucks to not sucks
is bad
[Laughter]
you have got to get some more income
coming in and really your long-term
career has got to get better would you
agree
uh yeah you don't want to be making
thirty thousand when you're 50.
right so what are you gonna do what's
going to move the needle you got you
keep doing what you've been doing you're
going to keep getting what you've been
getting agreed
yes sir yeah so we've got it we got to
work on the career side short term long
term and we've got to work on organizing
the money and the expenses in a budget
in the short term and you can walk right
straight through this hold on we'll have
Austin pick up we'll give you a copy of
Total Money Makeover and get you going
well and the fear you're feeling right
now it's super uncomfortable but I want
you to turn that fear into the what we
call here gazelle intensity where you're
like a gazelle running away from a
cheetah and the good news is with ten
thousand dollars this can be gone
quickly it's scary right now and it
feels overwhelming because you're
looking at all these bills and you're
behind and there's debt but you can
tackle this quickly especially if you
take that fear and turn it into focus
and use it to propel you forward into
knocking this out yeah I think you're
right if you're standing in the middle
of the interstate and an 18-wheeler is
coming you feel discomfort yeah and
that's that's a good discomfort get out
of the freaking row it's time for a
change where your stamming is going to
get you killed and that's what you're
saying here where the way I've been
doing things has got to change on the
income side and on the outgo side it has
to change otherwise next year you're
going to be sitting exactly here with
the exact same stresses different names
and the exact same bill problems
different names yep and so the good news
is you can just decide today Ready set
go this is America even in California
it's still America you can still go do
this and you can get out of that and you
can change this whole thing and you need
to look long term at your career and
what you're going to do but short term
right now I just want you to go get some
Monday and clean this mess up Renee's in
Denver hi Renee welcome to the Ramsey
show what's up
thank you for taking my call today
sure how can we help
um I'm calling because I'm looking for
some guidance and motivation as my
husband and I enter baby step number two
um I'm struggling with letting go of all
the control of our finances and working
with him on this because our debt seems
pretty overwhelming and even though I
know where to start I can't seem to get
focused enough to make any progress
well you're not surrendering control
you're just letting someone else have a
vote
wow you have a lot you still have your
vote
it's hard for me to to work with him we
don't see eye to eye on a lot of things
um so it's difficult for us to have
those so it's not a control issue it's a
disagreement issue
yes if you were in agreement and both of
you were voting that our goal is to get
out of debt the only thing we're arguing
about is how to get there that wouldn't
be nearly as big a problem as I don't
really care if we get out of debt versus
you want to you're saying I want to get
out of debt am I missing something
no you're right I think that we're both
just overwhelmed it seems like we're
being pulled in 80 different directions
with our debts
um so we're disagreeing on where exactly
to start he wants to start with one debt
and I want to follow the normal baby
steps
what like how does a conversation go
when you sit down and say hey we want to
start baby step two what's kind of his
opposition what's his perspective on
things
he wants to start with things that are
costing us the most money every month um
so the higher payment but his plan got
his plan got you here
so that won't work here's the thing
here's what I would here's my challenge
for him you can tell him I said this I
get it I kind of think the same way I'm
a math nerd but what I want you to do is
try my way for 90 days because I'm right
and you're wrong dude just try it for 90
days if I'm wrong you can go back to
your old broken way
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramseysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where that is Dom Cash's
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Christina
Alice Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author Confessions of a
scholarship winner is my co-host today
and you jump in we'll talk about your
life she and I get the opportunity to
talk a lot about student loan things
because she is probably one of the
leading experts in the entire world on
the student loan epic failure called
Washington D.C and uh the story
continues
the drama continues yes so um President
Biden announced that he's going to
forgive ten thousand dollars worth of
student loans for anyone making less
than 125 000 court cases have ensued uh
questioning whether he has the
constitutional right to actually do that
um
and of course he did this before the
midterms uh when which was a politically
genius move by the way uh to try to get
that get everybody's eye off the ball of
the failing economy and so forth because
the looks most most experts say
regardless of your uh your political
leaning that the dims are going to take
a bloodbath at the midterms and so he's
doing anything he can to get the eye off
of that
and then this comes out and this not
from right leaning media Source from a
left-leaning media Source called NPR
very interesting yeah they're saying
that now up to 800 000 borrowers who
thought they were going to be part of
the relief may not be part of the relief
now those are borrowers who had Perkins
loans in ffel loans that were issued and
managed by private Banks but not
guaranteed by the federal but guaranteed
they're guaranteed by the federal
government but yes but guaranteed sorry
yeah but we're once the Mainstay of the
federal loan programs and until the ffe
ffel program ended in 2010 so if you've
got an old student loan prior to 2010 oh
in a remarkable reversal that will
affect the fortunes of many student loan
borrowers the U.S Department of
Education is quietly
changed its guidance
around who qualifies for President
Biden's sweeping student loan student
debt relief plan this from NPR today
according to Federal data more than 4
million borrowers still have
commercially held ffel loans until
Thursday the Department's own website
advise these borrowers that they could
consolidate these loans into Federal
Direct Loans and thereby qualify for
Relief under Biden's debt cancellation
program but on Thursday the department
quietly
changed that language so as not to raise
a Ruckus in the media uh uh we read it
we read it we read it so the quiet part
goes away now
because there's 22 million of you out
there so we just uh made the quiet part
go away you just found out that they did
this
I told you when this happened that it
was not going to work exactly the way
they said it was going to work and
besides that they haven't even said how
it's going to work completely I told you
that the Department of Education had no
notice ahead of time student loan dot
gov had no notice ahead of time that
there was going to be a student loan
forgiveness announced out of the White
House if you're going to announce a
sweeping program that the federal
government is going to have to Institute
prior to announcing it you normally if
you're the president would let the
Departments know that they're going to
have to Institute it they had no
knowledge of it hint everyone knew it
wasn't really going to happen
and here are the beginnings of the
unravelings an Administration official
tells NPR that roughly 800 000 borrowers
would now quietly
be excluded from relief I added the
quietly because quietly's all in this NP
article NPR article although it's not
quiet anymore see you put it out right
well I think that's the key is that we
kind of need to put that in the
megaphone because these are people who
are already breathing signs of relief
that they're already counting on this
forgiveness because Biden sounded
confident it was going to happen yeah
it's a little nervous so sad it's very
sad so sad you know you know what screws
up your hope
you want to steal your hope
when you place your hope in the wrong
things
let me tell you where to place your hope
okay there's two places that you can
count on the rest of them are Gonna Let
You Down
if you're looking at a picture of your
spouse sorry it's Gonna Let You Down
if you're looking at a picture of your
Mom and Dad sorry I'm Gonna Let You Down
if you're looking at a picture of your
boss
sorry Gonna Let You Down
if you're looking at a picture of Jesus
that one's going to work you can place
your hope there and if you look in the
mirror
you can place your hope there if you
look and you see a picture of President
Biden or president Trump either one you
place your hope there it's going to let
you down God's point in my picture in
the lobby Gonna Let You down because I'm
not responsible for fixing your life
you're responsible for fixing your life
and Biden is not responsible for fixing
your life and Trump is not responsible
for fixing your life it is your job to
fix your life our job is to tell you you
can do it Go kid go get them get him go
for it
but I'm not giving you any money you're
going to make the money to get out of
that I'm not gonna wave any magic wands
from over here I don't have one my
batteries are low on the one I do have
it doesn't work no Harry Potter action
here
we don't have that at Ramsey you're just
all we are is your biggest cheerleaders
and your teachers and your guide we will
show you how we believe you can do it we
can prove to you that you can do it if
you'll get off your assumptions and go
do it
well yes 100 yes there there have been a
lot of emotions around this you know
from the very beginning
lots of discussion we have a lot of
emotions around here we bottle them but
that being said I've talked to a lot of
people who of course there's people who
are upset and don't think it's going to
happen but there's a lot of people who
are genuinely counting on this counting
on this that's what I'm telling you
you're gonna have your your hope gets
screwed when you place your Hope on the
wrong things well how do you think
people should see this moving forward
people who are still qualified for this
do you think they should be nervous that
potentially they could quietly fall out
of it or what's kind of your thought on
how people could should look at this
uh my thought from day one has been
don't wait on them to fix your life
because by the time they get if they
actually do Institute this it may
require an act of Congress
many legal Scholars are saying that you
can't really spend 300 billion dollars
that's 300 000 million
without congress's approval you can't
just do that as a stroke of a pen as a
president you don't really have the
constitutional right to do that or at
least that's what some people are saying
I don't know much about it but this
sounds reasonable to me so it requires
an act of Congress and you know what
when we were kids we used to say well
that's going to take longer than an act
of Congress you know why we say that
because an act of Congress takes
freaking forever Congress is slower than
Christmas or gridlock they don't do half
of what they say they're going to do
three quarters 90 98.2 percent of what
they say they're going to do and so you
know if it requires an act of Congress
you're screwed if if Biden can really do
it with a stroke of a pen it's ten
thousand dollars you have ninety eight
thousand dollars in student loan debt
quit acting like your life's better go
get yourself out of debt
ten thousand dollars ain't gonna fix
your life by the way it's gonna help
and I'm not mad at you if you take it
but it it's I
yeah there's so many indications here
that this is so much about the midterms
and so much about Optics and posturing
and so much about politics more so than
actual financial planning so it's going
to be an interesting few months I think
yeah or 30 days from now yeah you know
we're 30 days after the midterm they
said that the the application should be
out anytime now so oh yeah very telling
that would be interesting we'll see if
it comes out before the midterms if you
actually have an application in your
hands a place to sign up on a website
that they've actually programmed so how
are you going to prove 125 000 income
limit in a year that's not closed
foreign
[Music]
holes in it's just like swiss cheese
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five right now you're hearing a lot
of Talking Heads in the news stirring up
fear about the real estate market if you
believe them you think the housing
Market's going to crash that it'll be a
repeat of 2008 but you're not hearing
the truth
you can't make decisions based on fear
you need facts and those aren't facts
here they are in 2008 there was a huge
supply of homes but not enough buyer
demand
and demand and supplier what Drive house
prices so home prices went down in 2008.
too many homes not enough buyers
but that's not what's happening today as
a matter of fact right now there's half
as many homes for sale as there are
buyers we have two buyers for every
house in the market today
that is not a recipe for a housing
market crash
we've done the hard work of vetting
agents who know your local market and
have the transactions to back it up to
connect with a real real estate agent a
Ramsey trusted agent it's free to
connect with them go to
ramseysolutions.com agent it's our
endorsed local providers program ELP is
a Ramsey trusted
ramsesolutions.com
agent Tiffany is with us in Arizona hi
Tiffany welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up
um so back in
2014 my husband and I bought a rental
house with my parents
and then in 2015 we remodeled it my
husband and I paid all the expenses and
my father did the work
and then
in 2016 my parents got divorced and it
was a very spiteful divorce against each
other
and my dad came to me and was like if
you give me five thousand cash under the
table
will be out of the rental property and I
was like I'm not going to do that
because you guys are both my parents I'm
knocking in the middle of it
so then he went down to the county clerk
and put a 20 000 lien on the property
so we could not sell it because there
was not enough equity to cover the lien
and we've tried paying him three times
he won't take the money because he has
to split with my mom
so we're just kind of stuck we don't
really know what to do next
foreign
confessions of someone who should not
have bought real estate in a partnership
huh
they're financially able to no that
wasn't what I said confessions of
someone that should not about real
estate in a partnership which is anyone
by the way because the only ship that
Won't Sail is a partnership including
one with spiteful divorced parents and
your dad is completely butthole oh my
God
I'm so sorry for you
what a jerk
okay so what's the property worth
it's worth 63 and we owe 17.
oh it's a big old property too
everybody's going to get rich on this
crap what's your household income
what's your net worth
about 500 000.
okay there's a couple of ways to go at
this
structurally
relationally and spiritually
okay
um
Justice would be served but not common
sense
by way number one
and it's not my suggestion but this will
work okay
way number one is you hire an attorney
and you sue the partnership in court for
the disillusionment of the partnership
assets and you for it and the judge will
force the sale of the house and he will
deal with the illicit twenty thousand
dollar lien in the process
okay and in other words the judge would
remove the twenty thousand dollar lien
because you could present evidence that
in State Court this is a state course
not a federal court move you'd have to
talk to an attorney it's going to cost
you ten or fifteen thousand dollars to
do this
okay and your butthole dad is out of the
picture forever because once you Sue
this jerk he's never going to speak to
you again okay
and he's a jerk yeah okay but that might
that may not be a big loss but it is
your dad it still breaks your heart
Dad should not do this to their
daughters by the way that's just it's
not normal that's strange
so um
but that technically is how you would
get out of a bad partnership is you sue
for the disillusionment of the
partnership assets the judge says you
have to sell it they sell it slow sale
with a real estate agent or at an
auction and he can also rule on the
illicit illegal lien which is what
you're telling me this is okay yeah in
the process uh now if you want to go
that route you can go that route that
would be Justice that'd be the the
correct thing would happen then is he
would not get the twenty thousand
dollars that he's not due the property
would be sold and the appropriate people
would get the money all you although you
would be out attorney's fees and you can
sue for those and throw them in there I
assume there's no partnership agreement
of course another problem
when you give your dad that money half
of that's mine so I feel like I'm in the
Middle where I can't make no it's not
it's like I'm not giving your dad
anything that's not the point yeah okay
yeah we're not you're not going that
route
okay your dad is not do any money
is he
I mean I no no his deal was he did the
work and you furnished the repairs that
was the deal
he's not due any money morally
did I miss something
we didn't pay him for the work
right you didn't get
for putting up the stuff either did you
no okay that was the deal
quick covering for this jerk
am I missing something
no I mean he helped with the down
payment too that was 5 000 but even when
we try to just give him the five
thousand cash he wouldn't take it we
tried giving him five thousand ten
thousand yeah here's the other way
here's the other way here's the other
way out
this is this is 90 headache and 10
percent
fruit
you know what I would do if I were you I
assume you're on the mortgage right
yeah I would I would pay off the
mortgage today
and sign a quick claim deed to these two
fools and let them go work it out and
walk away
just give it to them screw them
let them go burn them burn it down it's
63 000 who gives a crap you've got a
half a million you make 120. this is not
life-changing money to you
what is life-changing is your parents
are being twerps
yeah just walk away just toss them the
keys over your shoulder
and say you two figure this out good
luck you children
and just forget it I was waiting for a
closure it was worth over 200 000 and
they owed 90 and they sent it back to
the bank instead of selling it agreed to
sell it so money isn't really the issue
I'm not talking about them I'm talking
about you yeah this is not about money
this is about fools
cut yourself loose from Fools
now are you guys renting it is it
sitting vacant yeah we're
we're low like the value is that high of
the property the rental
um it's worth 1 000 a month so let me
tell you by the time you split all this
crap up if you spend fifteen thousand
dollars in attorney's fees instead of 17
000 paying off the mortgage and you go
through all this crap you're going to
end up with ten thousand bucks in your
pocket aren't you
well after everything's said and done
after all the crap goes on if you sue
them and do it and you fight through
this for two and a half years in the
legal system and you get this house sold
your net in your pocket is going to be
between ten and twenty thousand dollars
isn't it
yeah yeah it is the numbers you just
gave me
yeah happened in Illinois they passed a
new law that's effective one 123 that
we're if a lien expires which this one
expired in 2018 that you don't have to
go through the leaner to get it the
person who put the lien on to get it
removed
um because I apparently there were a lot
of contracts it's not the lien that's
the problem you're on a mortgage and a
deed with two fools
oh they're not their names are names
that property at all
same oh this is new information yeah
it's all in our name because they were
in I know this is super stupid I did
this but um they were in chapter 13. oh
you guys are under the is it under the
table family we do illegal stuff for a
living here okay yeah I you know I might
well I thought they were on the loan
with you and on the on the house okay in
this case I would just sue him
show him and get the lean removed that's
simple just suit just following with a
court follow with the court and get the
lean removed that simple and then don't
give them anything screw them that's the
way I mean just just when you if you
want to give them something someday
that's fine but not now
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today yes we
talked about that last call all the way
through the commercial break and you did
too that's why you listen to the Ramsey
Show because it's a little Cherry
springer-ish around here sometimes so
um oh my gosh
um so here's the thing finally in the
last 30 seconds got the information
before we move on to the next part that
the ownership of the property was in the
girl's name her and her husband own it
so the only hold mom or dad have on that
property is a moral hold where they did
a handshake
partnership
but there is no legal hold on that
property at all and dad has placed a
lien on the property that can be removed
with a small attorney's fee of three to
five thousand dollars so if you have a
contractor that you pay and they're
pissed and they say you owe me an extra
five grand but no that wasn't our deal
and they placed a lien on your property
you can sue that contractor and have
that removed have that lien removed for
you know a couple thousand bucks in
state court it's not a big deal it's a
quick hearing may even be you know maybe
just local small claims court even
possibly depending on how your area is
so see an attorney honey and just sue
the contractor that placed lien on your
property the the contractor
being your butthole dad will settle the
twenty thousand dollars for three
thousand bucks and walk away you give
them the three thousand dollars now you
own the property free and clear you have
no moral obligation to people who tried
to cheat you
in an Unwritten partnership agreement uh
to pay them anything you now just own
the property and they're just out to
plunge which is where they deserve to be
they were in Chapter 13 when you bought
the property anyway we used your name
your credit your money to buy the
property to start with the only thing
they did was come up with a really bad
idea and stick you in it
and so they get nothing which is exactly
what these two groups deserve parents
misbehaving on the Jerry Springer Show I
mean there's Ramsey Show and so that's
the title of that call
uh one last thing Christina's asking me
about something else what about the
Biblical scripture says to honor your
father and mother you are supposed to
honor the office
of Father the office of mother but we do
not honor your dad if he sexually
molests you
we honor the office of father but we do
not honor a sexual predator we do not
honor mom if she's doing cocaine and
stealing your children's college fund
you honor the office of mother but that
mother has has severed her rights to be
honored as an individual
because of her misbehavior biblically
speaking and so you're not biblically
bound to honor people who are
misbehaving in any situation well I
think that's important to highlight
because I think a lot of Christians can
feel guilt around that and there are
other families nothing as guilty as an
Evangelical Christian we can do guilt
better than almost anybody maybe
Catholics beat us but I mean it's we're
right in there together buddy we got we
got guilt down to a science but yeah
it's not there's nothing to feel guilty
of here you're not you're the victim
you're not the perpetrator all right
let's move on to something positive like
Nathan and Laura on the debt free stage
how much debt of you two paid off we
paid off 121 000. I love it how long did
that take eight months eight months and
your range of income during that time is
160. 160 what do you guys do for a
living we started a Content creation
agency uh based in Memphis so we do
commercial photography and video
production of course you do way to go
well done YouTube all right what kind of
debt was yours 121 000. it was our
mortgage you're weird people you have a
paid for house in Memphis we do we love
it what's the house worth uh about 125
one or I'm sorry 225 250. there you go
you just moved up considerably one
sentence good and how old are y'all I'm
26. and I'm 27. that's amazing and I
have a 250 000 pay for a house oh my God
you guys are awesome
boom boom
boom boom all right how'd you get
started on all this Ramsey stuff so when
we got married four years ago we came
into the marriage with no Consumer Debt
and really thanks to our parents we
didn't have any debt from college or
anything like that and so we really had
a clean slate and then
when we got married
um
like kind of right after that we started
the business and so three years ago we
kind of said you know if the Lord
chooses to bless our business we would
love to pay off our house and then be
able to help other people and really
invest back into our business and our
team and amen and amen and so
um this year once we we've started
hiring team members and once that kind
of start go start started going we said
you know we we really need to get this
debt going so that we can start on that
path and so we just hit it hard so were
your family's Financial Peace families
so I did Financial Peace Junior and had
the piggy banks and all that kind of
stuff I love it and your financial peace
babies yes and at 26 and 27 years old
you have a paid four quarter million
dollar house ding ding see what those
little banks will do those little banks
are powerful I'm just saying the
principal stick that's it yeah I truly
didn't know I didn't know that you could
buy a new car we've just always had used
cars and my family
I didn't know that was legal I didn't
know
well eight months you guys weren't
playing around that's a lot to do ten
thousand dollars a month yeah so what
did this did this look like what did
this journey laid into it we really just
kind of decided the beginning of this
year when we kind of saw that it was
going to be a good year for the business
we kind of decided you know hey let's uh
let's just pull more money out of the
business and get that debt gone so that
then we can use all of our cash flow to
give and put it back into the business
and really like Laura said pour into our
team members and uh pour into others
personally he's so understated we just
decided to put 15 000 a month on the
morning at the first of the year we just
decided we could do that yeah then it
won the thing and we just did it you
know well we had meetings like every I
feel like first of every month we were
like okay what are you working on what
am I working on like who are we you know
who are we trying to sell to right now
and it gives you a different reason to
sell when you get a big goal yes I like
it it does what was the hardest part
um I would really say I I feel like we
did a great job of being on the same
page
um but sometimes it was hard just to
want to put that much on the house
instead of in to other things what was
the month you put the biggest month
Chunk on remember what the biggest chunk
I think it was this month this month
yeah what was the biggest Chunk we put
60 on it oh 60 in one lick yeah
we just say we were like okay we're just
gonna wait and then put it off oh you
shaped up a little yeah okay we kind of
let it build up in the retained earnings
I feel right a 60 000 check at 26. I
know that's just like a gulp moment it's
like a roller coaster like whoa oh it
was kind of like you just don't think
about it like you just kind of do it and
say because you know like I'm very
business-minded so it's like oh well you
know we could go do this and do this and
it's like no we need to do this first
and then we'll have that later so this
gosh these guys are amazing you guys are
you got to dial them man you're gonna be
so rich it's gonna be so rich I wish I
was on commission it was just awesome
y'all did people think you were weird at
26 and 27 paying off they don't even
people don't even know well I I would
say I mean yeah I think it is very weird
among just our age group to be thinking
about that because we we kind of said
you know when we got married we have to
avoid lifestyle creep of just like
everyone around us is buying a big house
and they're getting new cars and that
sort of stuff and
um our parents did a great job with that
too yeah so I think just you know not
thinking we had to do everything in the
order that ever everybody else is doing
it and then I'm so proud of y'all yeah
way to go Heroes and I know your mom and
dad are sitting here they're proud of
you well done very very well done good
stuff hey we got a copy of Total Money
Makeover for you a copy of our
membership to financial peace and a baby
steps millionaire book for you that's
the next chapter in your story if you're
not already there by the way how much do
you have in Investments uh about 50.
okay so you're on your way then all
right so next order of a business is to
finish up the baby steps millionaire
Journey so that's the next chapter in
your story and you'll be there about
what 31 years old yeah oh my God you
guys are awesome wow wow so cool so cool
mom and dad are over there grinning
they're not gonna be living in the
basement yeah this is these two made it
this is so good so good well done all
right Nathan and Laura Memphis Tennessee
house and everything
everything 121 paid off in eight months
making 160. count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three three two one
[Music]
pay for your parents out there you got a
12 year old running around with the
piggy bank that's your future this is
how you change your family tree baby
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today this is the Ramsay show
Steve's in Columbus Ohio hi Steve how
are you
great how are you better than I deserve
what's up
all right well thanks for taking my call
as of probably about a year ago you
didn't even know that Dave Grant we
should have had a disc but since then
I've been listening to you guys in the
radio in your podcast well thank you
I'm very thank you so what I've done
since then I've already eliminated some
small debit cards on credit cards okay
your phone's going in and out if you can
speak directly into it maybe that'll
help
okay I'm sorry so so since then I have
refinanced my house from a five-year
or a 30-year five percent six or eight
to the 15-year two and a half percent
rate which saved me a ton of money I
would have never known to have done that
unless I was listening to you guys cool
so now the only debt that I have is my
house payment and the car payment but
what like kind of one of my questions is
there no I have twenty two thousand
dollars in cash and a safety deposit box
and I probably keep about twenty
thousand dollars cash for my savings
what would you recommend that I do with
that I'm 48 years old and have no
retirement
okay so you're a hundred percent debt
free except your home
except for the home and a truck payment
that I probably like seven thousand
dollars okay first thing I'm gonna do is
pay off the truck
okay today
and now you're debt free and then you
need to set aside three to six months of
expenses as an emergency fund
of that money so what do you think three
to six months of expenses sounds like
uh well my house payment is only 8.50 a
month so what's your household income
um so right now I'm seeing Warren
engaged but just mine alone I make forty
dollars an hour and I average probably
about 45 hours
okay so will you pay taxes on a year
um I think it's around 23 2400.
a year
yep now what's your annual incomes what
I'm asking Oh My English my annual
income for me is probably about 80 000
that's what I was thinking okay okay I'm
sorry so let's call three to six months
of expenses twenty thousand bucks for
the fun of it
okay and we're going to set that money
aside and never touch it for anything
it's there just as an umbrella when it
rains
yeah I don't want to I don't want to
kind of do it anymore I don't want to
kind of do it I want to label it that
and then never touch it
okay I have kind of forgotten about it
yeah unless there's an emergency you
don't touch it
okay and our new bass boat is not an
emergency
I understand that yeah okay and so
advertising the systems I've been
listening to you I'm like do I really
need this
then the rest of it we're going to move
on to the other baby steps and start
your retirement account and you need to
set up a Roth IRA and anything else you
can set up to get going on your savings
and start saving for retirement
okay and your your smartvester pro can
help you with that if you just go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on
smartvester and so Christine that's an
example of a lot of that that guy's a
natural saver
he's done a good job yeah really good
job I mean he's got money there and he's
got not got much debt a little seven
thousand dollar truck payment I'm way
ahead of most Americans by far you know
but but he's sitting there and he but
he's listless and hasn't yet used the
power of His income
to not only get out of debt first but
then to point it towards something other
than just piling up cash in a safe
deposit box
and start pointing it towards wealth
building because if the inflation rate
is nine percent and that's what they say
it is that means every uh ten thousand
dollars that is in there is losing nine
hundred dollars a year
out
in two years that's two thousand dollars
you lost sitting in the safe deposit box
in purchasing power
right and so you can't let money just
sit in a stack of Benjamins it goes down
in value and I remember when I first got
on the air I had this whole hillbilly
guy call me I loved it was a great call
because people it reminded me my whole
growing up years and he's like yeah I
got twenty thousand dollars buried in
the coffee can somewhere out in the yard
what do you think of that and I'm like I
think that's really dumb on a whole
bunch of fronts
number one your neighbor might have a
metal detector and he's out there with a
beep beep beep looking around in the
middle of the night you wonder what's
going on out there uh number two uh
paper left with moisture around it and
bugs will deteriorate you might go out
there and find nothing but a little pile
of confetti where your money used to be
and number three you know what twenty
thousand dollars is in seven years it's
forty thousand dollars you know what it
is in seven more years it's eighty
thousand dollars you know what it is and
seven more years a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars and so in the last 21
years you have lost a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars with that money sitting
in a coffee can you know I think I'm
gonna dig it up I think you need to son
so that you know that's called
opportunity cost we talk about that in
High Finance it's the missed opportunity
that the money could have had yep yeah
and I think it's awesome that he's a
natural saver because when somebody like
this finds a plan then they typically
get on fire and they're good at
executing they're we're not having to
deal with changing habits we're not
having to deal with you know cutting off
a spending bleed but this person's gonna
find this and just dive in and be on
track for wealth quickly
a spending bleed a spendingly there
could be a spending bleed in the culture
people could there could be a lot of
people bleeding to death with their
spending bleed yeah that's very possible
yeah because what you're talking about
is most people spend more than they make
they spend money like they're in
Congress right and uh you know he's not
he's doing a really good job so well
it's like if you've got the spending
blade we have not only the principles
that you need to learn yeah
we can stop the bleeding baby it's what
we do yeah we will we will light you up
Jeanette's with us in Sacramento hey
Jeanette what's up
yeah thank you for taking my call um my
husband and I are in our late 50s and uh
we have uh some money in the bank minus
our emergency fund that's all set we
have about 350 000. we owe 305 on our
house
and uh our adult children have recently
moved to Florida so we're considering
buying a condo there we could take that
money in the bank and buy cash buy the
condo with cash or we could pay off our
first mortgage and we're just wondering
what you think would be the better thing
to do
if you buy the condo are you going to
keep the house you're in right now
yes and we our goal would be to spend
about four months a year in Florida so
like two months in Sacramento one month
in Florida and back and so we don't have
to rent a hotel and that kind of a thing
so we you know they're in the military
so it may only be a three or four year
thing that we would keep that condo
so we're just debating if interest rates
higher now and our current interest rate
on the home we have is 2.85 and this
this 350 000 in the bank is that just
cash sitting there or where'd that pile
of money come from that's sitting there
because we have not been sure what to do
what's your household income
or buy about 300 000 a year good for you
well done you've done a great job okay
so your question is a question of
prosperity
um I'll tell you what we believe and
what I did personally okay I've got a
nice Lake home and I've got some other
properties as well that are for family
enjoyment
okay
um those are called toys
so a Florida condo is a toy
you pay cash for toys and you pay cash
for toys after your home is paid off
so what I would do is I would write a
check and pay off my house today and
then I would begin to aggressively save
if I want to buy a condo but in the
meantime I just go over there and get me
a real nice Airbnb or just go you know
for less than three hundred thousand
dollars uh you can rent a house
just rent it for the year
I mean wouldn't cost that much
I mean what could you what could you
rent that 300 000 condo for probably two
thousand a month
you know oh they've gone up quite a bit
like 3 200 a month oh okay all right so
thirty six thousand instead of three
hundred thousand
so and here's what you're going to find
out I did this one time okay I was I was
hell-bent on a certain property that I
shall remain nameless that I wanted to
live in I mean I wanted to have as a
second home it was a vacation home and
my my wife was convinced we needed it
too so we had talked ourselves into it
so we went and rented one for a year and
we went up there four times in a year
and we counted up what we could have
stayed in the freaking Penthouse in the
Ritz Carlton for that instead of and not
had to deal with the maintenance
yeah all that so yeah we figured out it
wasn't such a great idea after all and
that renting experience taught us that
we didn't want to be an owning person in
that type of property so yeah I would
rent for a year and I pay off my house
just what I'd do this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
real amazing relationships Christina
Ellis Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we launched a new podcast at Ramsey
here about uh 10 days ago and it has
gone to number one on all the sites it's
called smart money happy hour with
George Campbell and Rachel Cruz hosting
and uh and drinking and talking and
hosting and laughing and drinking and
talking and the two the two of them
they're just straight up funny they're
fun and the podcast is a huge hit on
already it's I hit number one on a whole
bunch of the lists and already several
million people lining up so check it out
smart money happy hour the newest
podcast from the Ramsey Networks
also on this show the show continues to
dominate the podcast world the talk
radio world and even the YouTube world
if you like this show help us out by
subscribing to it however you're
consuming it with us podcaster YouTube
leave a review uh especially if you
think it's like five stars if you think
it's awful don't leave a review we don't
want to hear from you we we only want
five star reviews and we want here's the
big thing more important than either one
of those things is share it with
somebody tell somebody listen to this
stuff it's life-changing if you'll tell
somebody that helps us and it helps them
it helps you everybody's winning all the
way around so pods has come alongside us
the PODS moving and storage and is the
new studio sponsor we got a little pod
back here on the shelf behind us and
proud to have these guys the leadership
team is a team that we align with on so
many things just good good people and we
know a lot of you are planning on moving
soon and so as a part of being the new
studio sponsor PODS moving and storage
wants to help one of you move
for free
yeah so here's what you do you go to
pods.com Ramsay between October 3rd and
October 14th and you can enter to win a
free move it's really simple that's
amazing one listener is going to get a
free move or a free storage rental up to
a five thousand dollar value and you can
move with pods a lot cheaper than that
by the way look pods just makes moving
easier with the flexibility you need the
control you want the customer service
you deserve it's an incredible company
they're going to take great care of you
they'll drop the Pod off with a podzilla
delivery system it's Pretty stinking
incredible keeps everything level so all
your stuff doesn't like schlep to the
back and crash into each other and break
everything after you so carefully packed
it in there instead it lifts it
perfectly level it's like the claw right
remember that in Toy Story the claw yeah
if you're if you're looking for a
company that will help you move on your
terms pods is the only Ramsay trusted
moving provider and so what you're doing
to get the free move you sign up between
October 3rd October 14th to win no
purchases necessary of course go to
pods.com Ramsay and enter to win a free
moving or Storage Rental today pods.com
Ramsay good stuff this is a great
partnership with these guys yeah that's
amazing having just moved earlier this
year it can be a lot and very stressful
so a free move is an incredible giveaway
Brian's in Seattle hey Brian how are you
not bad how you guys doing better than
we deserve sir what's up in your world
uh so I got a divorce about a year ago
and I have full custody of me of my
children and according to the courts
Mike exos me just under seventy thousand
dollars and it became obvious I was
never going to see a dime of it so I
kind of gave up on that uh but I really
needed the money I was a few days away
from missing a house payment and my
parents figured out what was going on
and they bailed me out
um and I'm beyond grateful I'm doing way
better than I deserve and I have a paid
for home now as a result of it and right
now though the the thing that the
question is that she's not going to sign
the quick claim deed and I just I don't
want to stir up any problems oh too late
I keep the peace too late
she has a court order she has a court
order
yeah she's gonna sound quite clean dude
she's got about 20 seconds Ready Set Go
this is ridiculous it's ridiculous
let me just tell you let me tell you
your wife your ex-wife is not very smart
she does not want to be in contempt of
court they put people in jail for that
crap
yeah so here's what we're gonna do you
have your attorney
call her old attorney
and tell him you have five minutes to
get this signed or we're going to file
with the judge and the judge is going to
put her in jail for contempt to court
after he tells her to sign it if she
doesn't sign it instantly judges don't
screw around with this stuff they're
kind of bossy that's why they call them
judges
the the thing that I'm I'm kind of
worried about is that she's kind of high
conflict and I just so am I put the kids
in the middle of a high conflict the
kids aren't in the middle of it kids
ain't got nothing to do with it yeah
chick needs to sign one piece of paper
that the court told her she had to sign
it's not high conflict this is how
stupid
yeah your kids are in the middle of
nothing
just just she just needs to be smacked
into next week metaphorically speaking
also you said you have full custody what
does that relationship look like with
your kids and her
uh I I try to make sure that she gets
her visitation so she has you know
supervised visits and stuff like that
but that's fine um
yeah that doesn't even enter into it
you're abiding by the court order only
visitation aren't you
yeah and she has missed two of three on
the I mean she's missed the other two
number one 70 grand no show number two
sign the quick claim deed gonna show
baby
you owe your parents this
you're scared of her aren't you
a little bit
I can't blame you really because I think
this one is a test pilot for a broom
factory man
well and as a parent I do I do feel the
empathy of wanting to protect your kids
but I think it's important to do to the
kids there's a guy he don't want to deal
with her she is way too much trouble to
deal with and that's why she's the ex
that's why they call them exes
yeah but dude you got to get your house
this is not going to go well you think
it's going to get better by not dealing
with it it's gonna get worse
conflict conflict delayed is conflict
Amplified Dr John deloney says
yeah it's gonna get bigger isn't it so
splinter under the skin it's going to
fester and then you're gonna have to
have your hand cut off because you're
gangrene
you got to deal with it you got to deal
with it it's an algae but you got to
deal with it
well and I think this is actually a way
to protect your kids I think that
dealing with this is going to actually
give you a little bit more control over
this relationship versus dragging it out
for years like this needs to be cut off
this needs to be done but here's the
thing it's not getting to do with your
kids kids aren't even in the equation
I'm not going to talk about the kids
about it it's not kids stuff it's adult
stuff
you just be sweet to the kids and you be
sweet to them when you drop her off you
don't run her down to the kids even if
she is a twerp you're still not going to
run her down the kids you just speak
highly of their mom and you just be a
good man a man of nobility who enforces
the law
and the law is the law said the judge
said with the hammer on the gavel
sign the quit claim deed have your
attorney contact her attorney today dude
do not put this off you have got to deal
with this it's going to get worse it's
not going to get better
this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Christina Ellis number one best-selling
author and my co-host this hour Ramsey
personality joining us joining us uh one
of our good friends Ambassador or
Governor or Ambassador or Governor Nikki
Haley is with us got a brand new book
out hey Ambassador how are you
I'm great how are you better than I
deserve I always hesitate whether to
call you Nikki or not it feels like a
breaking protocol
it's Nikki those are moments in times
you've been on here three or four times
with us so we feel like we're old
friends and we love you we appreciate
you we are the brand new book last time
you were over here you told us this was
coming if you want something done
uh yeah get a lady to do it Leadership
Lessons from Bold women what a great
book
oh the back of it says ask a woman oh
Margaret Thatcher if you want something
done dot dot dot on the back of the rest
of the title of it see the design now
ask a woman good
so it's based off of the Thatcher quote
that was if you want something said ask
a man if you want something done ask a
woman and I am a huge Margaret Thatcher
fan and you know have always loved the
fact that she
um believed in Britain but more
importantly she believed in herself and
you know as I went to the United Nations
I learned a lot about Gene Kirkpatrick
who was my predecessor who was
Unapologetic
um about you know when it came to
America and just loved her country and
she wasn't a politician by any means but
she found her strength you know and then
went on and I met people like Nadia
Morad who lived in Iraq her family was
killed by ISIS she was taken
um and gang raped and you know
trafficked and she came out of it
stronger and actually helped hold her
Isis you know abusers accountable and
you know may basically made the entire
world hold them accountable and really
hold them at fault and help the yazidi
community or you know it was just Cindy
warmbier who I met and she was the
mother of Otto warmbier who was tortured
by North Korea and the idea that she
could take that Unthinkable pain and
make sure she put the fight back to
North Korea so it's just these are
ordinary women who became extraordinary
Wilma Rudolph is in there right
that's a good Tennessee story I had her
on the show when she was alive she was a
force of nature
I mean think about the idea woman
Romeo wore brace until she was 12 years
old and in eighth grade decided to run
when they thought she would never be
able to walk and here she's the first
female to win three gold medals in an
Olympics for track it's remarkable you
know the Wilma Rudolph Boulevard
downtown Nashville yeah she was from
Clarksville yeah she was she was a force
of nature I mean amazing just her
presence in the studio but that's
powerful very cool did you get to meet
Wilma
no I wish I could have but I just loved
her story I thought it was just amazing
and so these are stories you know when I
look back I think parents know that
strong girls become strong women and
strong women become strong leaders and
what I hope is that parents will go out
and you know get this book for their
girls and let them know they deserve to
be in the room I hope this is motivation
for young professional women that are
growing through the ranks I hope this is
used as a thank you for mentors and
leaders who have helped women along the
way and I hope that this is a reminder
that our world is better because we have
women in it I think men will enjoy
reading this book too but I think more
than anything I want it to be a reminder
to women that you know nothing comes
easy but when you work hard you can
really make a difference in the world I
love that as a mother of a young
daughter that just makes me so excited
to read it and it comes out tomorrow
October 4th tell us a little bit about a
little bit more about what people can
read in the book and just what they're
going to get away from it
so you know it'll it'll highlight people
that you've heard of like the
Problem Solver and to hear all that she
did for Israel and the different twists
and turns that went along the way and
she never gave up to people who you may
not have heard of like Claudette Colvin
which you know everyone knows that Rosa
Parks was the woman in Alabama who
refused to get up from the bus
but what they don't know is actually she
wasn't the first one nine months earlier
Claudette Colvin had been studying the
constitution in her school and at 15
years old she sat in the bus and refused
to get up she was literally the first
one that was taken arrested ridiculed
known as the girl that was arrested in
Montgomery and because she was young
they thought she was emotional and
feisty they thought she didn't look the
part so they waited nine months got Rosa
Parks who was a member of the NAACP
someone who was more mature someone who
they felt like was more disciplined and
they used her as the person that did it
but think about a 15 year old girl
having the courage and strength to do
that first because stories like that
that are just remarkable a straight up
Swagger I mean that's that's incredible
very very powerful the book is if you
want something done ask a woman
Ambassador Nikki Haley is our guest this
segment she is the ho the author of this
she is a New York Times best-selling
author with the first book with all due
respect
um which is what people say right before
they disrespect you
it's the southern way of kicking you
with a smile now bless your heart which
can mean I'm going to Slit your throat
yeah
so you've written about all these
inspiring women but do you have someone
who's the most inspiring woman for you
personally
it's of other women and you know if you
go to the story I do a story about
Amelia Earhart as well and you know many
people think of her as
um you know the female pilot who
basically got lost trying to fly around
the world but that's not what her story
was about her story was very much about
the fact that she loved to see women
successful and female Pilots back then
weren't allowed to fly alone they had to
have a male counterpart with them when
they flew and she started this team
called the 99s which were 99 female
Pilots that just wanted to be able to
fly alone and she cheered them on and so
you know I now I have so many that I
think are inspirational of course my mom
will always be my first inspiration and
she
um you know grew up in India and was a
lawyer and became one of the first
female judges but because of the times
in India she was never able to sit on
the bench so the idea that she couldn't
do it but that she raised the daughter
who became the first female minority
governor in the country shows that
strong women breed strong women and you
know and allowed me to learn from her
and then you know you look at Margaret
Thatcher and the idea that you know she
took on
um you know a time where socialism was
the norm in Britain you know government
was continuing to rule and she basically
erased
um 40 Years of socialism in 10 years by
making sure she privatized government
Industries like steel and air and she
made sure that she cut taxes and she
showed that when you have more money in
your pockets that's how you get the
economy to turn and you know she got a
tremendous amount of pressure to reverse
that and a tremendous amount of pressure
that she was going the wrong way and she
never let the heat get to her she stayed
true to who she was and ended up being a
celebrated leader now one of the most
powerful ever in Britain really I mean
Churchill asked in so many ways uh the
the social movement that she caused was
really a revolution and if you don't
believe me visit some of the mines in
Scotland they'll tell you some of them
still don't like her
you know when she was called The Iron
Lady and interestingly enough the
Soviets gave her that name and they gave
her that name as a joke but she wore it
as a badge of Pride and you know as a
badge of honor and and became The Iron
Lady and what was a very respectable
term after that Ambassador Nikki Haley
Our Guest this segment again the book is
if you want something done ask a woman
it comes out tomorrow it has a pretty
recognizable bright green cover I love
your creative on it very very well done
it'll jump off the bookshelves and not
get lost in the shuffle but you've never
been lost in the shuffle since I've
known you so that's that's perfect for
you so thank you for standing up against
our crazy culture out there we're
watching you do it and we're praying for
you thank you for who you are in your
service to this country
thanks so much for having me on y'all
take care come by and see us my friend
Nikki Haley if you want something done
ask a woman powerful stuff this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
Christina Alice Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today our question of the day
comes from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free
free samples free shipping new promos
all the time it's a great deal this is a
wonderful company if you're going to put
a blind in your house this is the way to
do it blinds.com use Ramsay as your
promo code it's magical it'll get you
the best deal
today's question comes from Beth in
North Carolina my 18 year old has forty
thousand dollars in stocks that was
given to him by a family member to pay
for college should he pull money from
them to pay for each semester or pull
money from them and pay each year in
full is one option better than another
or does it not matter if he pulls from
them how does he figure out how much
he'll pay in taxes each year he cashes
out stocks it's an interesting question
I'll let you speak to the tax part but
I'll quickly cover the financial aid
part one of the biggest questions I
would have is is the financial aid
eligible because this money could
definitely impact that a lot of people
don't realize how assets can impact the
EFC equation which is your expected
family contribution so if you are a
student your assets are factored in at
20 percent whenever they're calculating
your financial aid and if that's income
it's factored at 50 so by pulling that
money in if he's still applying for the
fact FAFSA it could be counted as income
in a future Financial need equation
therefore it could reduce his
eligibility for future financial aid so
that's a factor that a lot of people
don't consider when they're looking at
it so what would be his best strategy in
that case
well he may not want to spend it at all
until the end of college if he can find
another way to go to school debt free he
may want to just leave that money
invested if he can get scholarships if
he can pay for it because right now it's
a student asset so student assets are
factored at 20 percent so that's eight
thousand dollars versus at the income if
he pulls it out his income is factored
in at 20 at 50 percent yeah but if he
pulls out uh if there's forty thousand
dollars he pulls out ten thousand
dollars it's five thousand dollars not
eight but the thing is is it just
depends on what his ultimate EFC is if
he's a high need Student that could not
come out of the running for different um
five thousand dollars could if it
increases it's EFC significantly so
um well and it's just that money could
be if he can get a scholarship instead I
mean it could be better to left leave
that money saved because if he's got a
zero if he can work and get scholarships
and not touch it that's going to be the
best for the equation yes especially for
future financial aid but eight thousand
dollars will still count against him
just because he's got it on the books
twenty percent of 40. yeah I mean it's
still gonna it's still gonna count so
it's just important to look at how your
income and assets are going to affect
you especially as a student so if it's a
parental asset it's only factored in at
5.64 so parental assets have a lot less
of a ding on the financial aid equation
what the crap do they get 5.64 I know
this is bureaucrats right it's just 5.64
is the exact number of actual oh my God
but it's just it's a conversation to
have a lot of a conversation to have but
at the end of the day no in no case are
we saying use debt to keep from messing
with this you use this money to avoid
debt at the end of the day if you have
to even if it messes up something else
but go get scholarships work leave the
money alone is the best for the formula
right but if you um if if the formula is
if you don't have access to anything use
the money pay cash for college as you go
now you're well go ahead it's also
important that this this family member
they put it in the student's name
perhaps they could have put it in the
parents 529 therefore it would have been
a parental asset but if they put that in
a brokerage account in stocks in the
student's name then that's just a
different Factor so if you're a family
member wanting to give student a student
money for college talk to the parent
because you could put it in the parents
529 and then that'll affect the FAFSA
differently yeah so just be strategic
about that because I've talked to
countless families who didn't really
know how that fact unless you're just
going to give them enough pay for
college and that's it right that's
fantastic just gonna pay for college
forty thousand pays for the Hulk schools
and that's different but it won't yeah
so in most cases anyway yeah I wrote
about it in my second book how to
graduate debt free just how parents and
students can look at their income and
assets to make sure they're doing it the
most strategic way an informed way so
that they don't accidentally ding
themselves on the FAFSA just not knowing
yeah now you're answering your tax
question is this your basis for tax
calculation is in other words the
equivalent of what you paid for it it
would be your basis normally but with a
gift your basis is the value of the
stock at the time he received it
so it's worth forty thousand dollars
today let's say that it was worth thirty
thousand dollars when he received it and
it's gone up to 40. he only pays tax on
the gain over what it was worth when he
got it
that's all okay and so he needs to
figure out what the value was at the
time he received the gift of the
portfolio and there's probably sitting
with a broker the broker probably do
that one phone call one email all right
and so uh whoever the financial advisor
that's helping you with this can
probably do that and then you're going
to pay he's going to pay taxes at the
capital gains rate of 15 percent over
what he paid for or what it was worth at
the time he received it and so in my
example if he cashed out the whole
stinking thing and it was worth 30 when
he got it it's worth 40 now he has a ten
thousand dollar taxable event at 15
percent the taxes are fifteen hundred
bucks and so it's not it's not bad so
your your basis in a gift is the value
at the time no wait a minute
that's on Estates I just did that wrong
all the CPAs out there are throwing
Rotten Tomatoes at the radio right now I
screwed that up no the basis is what the
guy that gave it to him paid for it
it's worse
well the family member what they paid
for it is the basis on a gift
it's not he did not inherit it it's not
an estate it stepped up basis in an
inheritance but on this in this case you
guys can all send me hate mail on
Twitter and everything else you do
anyway but yeah I screwed that up I
almost screwed it up I fixed it yeah you
got it caught it halfway through my as I
stumbled across the line and fumbled the
ball and missed the Super Bowl but
anyway yeah the uh uh yeah so yeah
that's it you you have to find out what
the family member paid for this set of
stocks that he gave to your
18 year old and that let's say and
that's probably a lot less
well you got a lot of taxes here yeah
and to quickly go back to the income so
if they took out that forty thousand
dollars
um in one single calendar year and it's
factored in at 50 of their income then
that reduces their aid eligibility in
future years by 50 so that's twenty
thousand all the future years as well
next year over next year the following
year okay so it's actually a twenty
thousand dollar thing so one thing they
could have done would have been to cash
it out when he was a senior in high
school
and put it into an Esa or junior year
because now it's prior prior yeah yeah
if you go away to Junior that'd be even
better but yeah if it was that long ago
and and that way it doesn't affect your
formula and it gets it out of single
stocks and put it in something else
right where it's not as volatile uh
because I don't know what this portfolio
looks like so there's a lot going on
here uh the bottom line is We're not
gonna look at gift horse in the mouth
haha this is a gift and so uh there's
lots of good things about getting forty
thousand dollars that I can count that
or beat any kind of equations for uh
financial aid or beat a little bit of uh
capital gains taxes so it's a wonderful
wonderful gift we'll just have those
conversations because it could be a
simple conversation sophomore year could
save you you know four thousand eight
thousand dollars in the long run and
that's worth it just simply by having
that knowledge and if you moved it into
a 529 in a mutual fund it going up in
value of no taxes from that point
forward so you would limit the taxes and
you would have limited the damage to the
thing if you'd have moved it ahead of
time so there we go now we got a good
strategy should the sophomore you remove
it then Kim's in Philadelphia hi Kim
Welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Christina hi Dave
sure what's up
Okay so so a caller a few weeks ago I'm
not sure but
had been talking about some social
security death benefits that he had
received for several years
and at the end of the conversation you
kind of gave you said well that's not
what I would do with them but he didn't
really elaborate on that so I'm calling
to ask for a little bit more elaboration
on that my kids I have three kids and
we're getting Social Security death
benefits actually all four of us get
them but I had your husband pass
he passed this just past June oh I'm so
sorry
thank you and what I would do is what I
would do simply this I would integrate
them into the budget
because you spend you spend more raising
these kids than the government is giving
you so you are not stealing their money
you're not stealing their money I would
just integrate it into the budget make
it part of your income uh and you take
care of your kids take care of their
college you take care of their life you
buy their clothes you pay them pay for
the doctor bills and all of that adds up
to way more than you're getting in
Social Security so you're not taking
their money from them and doing
something else with it you're taking
care of them in excess of money you're
receiving take care of them so I would
integrate it into the budget is what I
teach this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today Romans 15 13 May the
god of Hope fill you with all joy and
peace as you trust in him so that you
may overflow with hope by the power of
the Holy Spirit
Martin Luther King Jr said out of the
Mountain of despair
a stone of Hope Oh man
good term phrase absolutely amazing
Christina Ellis and number one
best-selling author of Ramsay
personality is my co-host today Boca
Raton Daniel's on the line hi Daniel how
are you
I'm good Dave how are you doing better
than I deserve what's up
um a few things I think it's going to be
a kind of a three-part question
um so I have I've not been great at
managing money most of my life
um
and I have racked up a lot of debt not
in the hundreds of thousands
um but with like medical bills included
maybe 40 or 50.
um and I sat down with some friends
what I've decided to do is actually live
out of my car because I own it why not
um I'm still paying it off but it's you
know I have it and that's something I
can use and put all that money I would
put towards rent utilities towards
savings however I'm working baby step
one and three uh together before I move
on to two
um just I feel given inflation and where
things are at that might be the wisest
thing
um but I kind of wanted to tie into this
question on because I think a part of my
problem has been income
um and I think there's just more I could
do in that area and so I'm trying to see
if where in the baby sets paying for
college in cash might fit into that
to increase my income or if you even
think it's worth it or not to go to
college these days what do you make a
year
um well I'm a in multi-union management
I'm a district manager I'm making about
70 000.
multi-unit what's that mean
uh so you ever see multiple locations of
the company you're working for oh I see
okay
and are you in different cities all the
time are you just planning homelessness
oh I'm in multi I'm in a couple
different cities it just depends I
structure my week differently every week
do they give you some kind of travel per
diem allowance for hotels
well yeah I I I don't travel that far
um so that I don't pay any out of like
they reimburse between 66 cents a gallon
of gas
um but uh no there's no need for a hotel
oh I see okay
um
okay so you're asking our opinion on
this whole situation am I getting am I
Gathering that correctly
yeah I I you know I I made some of these
choices like moving in my car to get rid
of that yeah and get rid of everything
and then I appreciate that that is so
extreme I would not recommend it
okay I have never recommended someone
live out of their car in 30 years of
doing this you make seventy thousand
dollars a year I don't want you to rent
something for twenty five hundred
dollars a month but I want you to get a
roommate and get a cheap little
apartment of some kind and have a place
to unpack your stuff and take a freaking
shower
okay I mean I use a gym and all that I
know what you're doing I know exactly
what you're doing but I don't think it's
romantic at all
um I'm just telling you I think your the
quality of your life is gonna enter into
your ability to sustain
long-term working a plan
and you've gone so extreme that it's
going to be very difficult emotionally
you're untethered from everything
in this situation and so it's it's it's
one of the problems when we work with
the homeless Community it's one of the
problems they face emotionally is being
untethered
there's no anchor
to begin to build from a solid place and
that's the emotion that they feel you're
doing this intentionally so you're not
quote in the homeless Community but
you've chosen the exact same lifestyle
as a as a single mom who got thrown out
of our apartment is living in her house
and showering at the gym and it's the
exact same thing as a homeless in a
homeless scenario so I would choose to
have a a very very very very modest
place to live but a place to live number
one
um number two I'd look for any extra
jobs I can do to get my income up and
then number three you don't work the
baby steps out of order
yeah and I mean you can find even with
the room situation you can get a
roommate you can live in a room for 300
a month it may not be glamorous but it's
definitely better better than being
untethered yeah more more glamorous than
the back seat yeah and with the college
conversation Dave he mentioned paying
for college
um with 40 to 50 000 in debt would you
even consider that right now yeah I want
to get I want to get up and running and
what I would do is making seventy
thousand plus some extra work I'm going
to plow through this 40 or 50 000 in two
years and I'm gonna have an emergency
fund and then I'm going to save and pay
cash for college as I go and do we
recommend College as a long-term play
absolutely if it applies to your career
field generally just going I want to go
get a degree no I don't I don't
recommend that just as a you know an
opportunity to play beer pong for your
18 year old no thank you but we do say
you know if you're going into a field
where the academics the rigor of
Academia and the act the actual
knowledge base that you come out of it
with will be helpful and cause you to go
forward not just the degree but the
actual knowledge then yeah I would go
get that knowledge it is a barrier to
entry into some things it's a barrier to
progress and other things so yeah I
would do that but it's not a magic pill
like suddenly everything's gonna be okay
because it's got a college degree well
and that's I think part of the challenge
is he's making good money and I think
sometimes when they when people feel
overwhelmed when they feel uneasy uh
they kind of look at colleges that Auto
Solution like if I get a master's degree
then I'm going to make more money and my
problems will be solved and I've met
plenty of people who went into debt to
get a master's degree and they didn't
make that much more money or even any
more money at all really so I mean it is
good to go back to college if it's going
to truly get a master's degree in social
work and take a pay cut in his situation
right exactly so so College it's a great
conversation we're big advocates for
education but make sure the education
has a purpose and a point and it's not a
silver Financial
makes your life all good all of a sudden
that's not how it works but yeah so be
intelligent about that but what I would
do is go get a a roommate situation A
Modest apartment an extra job I'd get on
a tight budget I'd work the baby steps
in order thousand dollars and then I
want you to tear into these debts and
start plowing your way through them
you're going to be amazed when you don't
do anything out if you're willing to go
so Extreme as to live in your car
the extreme you can do with an apartment
and still get out of debt making 70
you'll be able to knock out forty or
fifty thousand I mean it's 25 000 a year
out of 70.
yeah and you're debt free in two years
you can do this
um you know you'll be done in short
order a lot faster than two years
probably you could be done in one year
depending on how much extra you work
you know you could make an extra 25
Grand yeah and be done in one year with
your income plus 25 Grand that's very
possible considering you do nothing else
with your life because you were going to
be living in the car and you know I mean
you're willing to go extreme that's for
sure so that that willingness tells us
your motivation is really high and
that's a wonderful thing you'll be able
to utilize that so Daniel we'll help you
with this I want you to go through
Financial Peace University as our guest
we're going to show you detail by detail
step by step how to do this stuff why to
do this stuff in order your situation is
not different you need to work the baby
steps in order there's a baby step two
that follows one for a reason
and you're not different
it is maybe step one then two then three
and
um you know don't talk to me about
inflation you're the guy that was
getting ready to live in his car
don't talk to me about you've got this
thing figured out you're the guy who's
gonna live in his car follow the
stinking program dude and we'll show you
how to do it we'll pay for it for you it
doesn't cost you a dime we want to help
you
and call us back and tell us how you're
doing say I was the guy that was almost
homeless you talked me out of it tell us
how I'll remember the call tell us how
you're doing if you just tell me you're
Daniel and Boca I won't remember it I
promise you but tell me the situation
it'll come right back to me I promise so
I'm proud of you I'm proud of you for
being willing to sacrifice a lot of
people in our culture aren't willing to
sacrifice we're too lazy yeah and if
you're willing to hustle and grind and
willing to sacrifice you can pull off a
lot of stuff in this culture today
there's a lot of wonderful things can
happen in your life so I'm proud of you
good work good work Christina Well done
well done today Austin Shelby Selby is
our assistant associate producer and
phone screener Ben Zach Andrew and James
the booth dudes are running the show in
there I am Dave Ramsey your host will be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]